un an après le lancement des travaux le
gratin du cyclisme français dont Grégory
Baugé vice champion olympique de vitesse
cet été à Londres visitait ce mardi le
chantier du futur Vélodrome implanté à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines des décembre
2013 cette structure unique abritera le
nouveau siège de la Fédération française
de cyclisme et la première arène de
piste de BMX couverte en Europe au sein
du complexe sera également mis en place
l'équivalent du Clairfontaine au
football un centre national du cyclisme
ou les membres de l'équipe de France
pourront venir s'entraîner tout cela
pour un investissement total de 68
millions d'euros mais il va falloir
encore patienter un an pour que les
grues laissent leur place aux roues de
vélo